you
oh hey it's TV at 2016 and we're about
to do a show floor tour but first we're
at the merch booth and I got 10,000 yen
that's burning a hole in my pocket let's
go spend
you
alienware is here showing up a lot of
new hardware including a laptop that is
I tracking software
one of the most highly anticipated games
2017 new is being shown here they're
showing a new area for demo gameplay
here at dgs
my three here in full swing they're
going big and they are open did you
start
I'm in over my head
shine
of course Final Fantasy 15 is here you
can play the full demo or you can just
turn around and observe some really rad
street art
I wanna rub this on your face there's a
really good chance i'm gonna play for
trying to fight before you
you
but the game's problem
honestly it's not teaching us about
Monster Hunter and this year it's
monster hunter stories go check it out
now there's my third TGS but not many
companies go bigger than sony they got
resident evil they got Final Fantasy 15
and they even got gravity days two and a
Pippin a lot of other games like last
guardian which i think is coming out on
the playstation six anyway I got a lot
of games go check it out
wow that was most if not all of t ZX
2016 you guys saw me by a bunch of merch
you're going to want to watch the lobby
because that's what we're going to be
giving it away probably when I get back
in like a week or so anyway definitely
stay tuned for more TTX coverage like
gamespot let me get it out of here I am
so sweaty
you